6 15. I'm proud to be the MC for
tonight's second annual night on block
or night in white to raise money for and
awareness of one of our eight news now
Community Pride Partners the
collaboration Center Foundation
the president and CEO Linda touche it's
benefiting the individuals family
members and caregivers with intellectual
Developmental and physical disabilities
of all ages at our magnificent five acre
ranch campus at last year's first annual
event a red carpet welcome yummy food
from some of the community's best
restaurants started a great evening that
included jaw-dropping entertainment in a
comfy outdoor setting we honored Linda
Smith one of the founders of Opportunity
Village who now has the non-profit
Christopher Smith foundation and this
year we are honoring the beautiful and
amazing Michelle de Rocher I am so
excited
we're over the moon for you too Michelle
and for your family now also being
honored Dana blackhurst and former Las
Vegas mayor Jan Jones blackhurst
promises to be a great evening 8 news
now proud to count the collaboration
Center Foundation as one of our
Community Pride partners